what's a single girl like you doing around
this big house i assure you i'm married
to a man a human one
Wanda
aren't we a fine pair?
I want us to fit in is this really
we just don't know what to expect
We are an unusual couple
oh i don't think that was ever in question
we just don't know what to expect
howdy neighbors hey buddy
wanda what's up! Who are you? I don't know.
i think something's wrong. Wanda, can you hear me? Who is doing this to you?
This is our home. Then let's fight for it.
Well I think we handled that well.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel dropped
another new Wandavision trailer with a bunch more
x-men and mutants easter eggs especially with
their twins i'll explain what's going on and how
they're using the series to introduce new x-men
characters to the mcu and how that's leading up
to a big young avengers crossover with the other
stuff that they just announced with all those
other characters if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i
will be doing Wandavision episodes starting in
january obviously there'll be more stuff coming
up too they just announced some bonus episodes
for the series called marvel legends those are
both dropping the week before Wandavision starts
january 8th and they'll just be bonus episodes for
scarlet witch and visions characters in the mcu
so i'll probably do some videos for that stuff too
kevin feige told a joke a little while ago about
scarlet wish and vision saying that they're the
two most powerful mcu characters with the most
ill-defined powers that's a good thing and a bad
thing he was making fun of what they've done with
those characters in the past the lack of character
development that they've given them but the good
part of that is that he's saying it gives them
the wiggle room to backdoor explain mutants and
x-men stuff in the mcu heading into marvel phase
4 and phase 5 and get really trippy with the way
they tell their story and have it all make sense
without breaking their own continuity like scarlet
witch using the mcu equivalent of her chaos magic
to change this bubble alternate reality that's
playing out like a tv show and they can say
well we never said she couldn't do that so they're
using that to sew together all this upcoming x-men
stuff that they're laying the track work for
right now and the multiverse or spider-verse
story depending on which marvel phase 4 movie
you're talking about big shout out for spider-man
3 which based on all the characters that have been
announced in the past two weeks sounds like it's
going to be even bigger than avengers end game i
am sure the memes for that movie will be off the
charts am i not supposed to have what i want what
i need there are a bunch of new scenes in this new
trailer of them holding their twins as children
it's wiccan and speed or billy and tommy which
are their actual names that they'll probably just
call them during the series wigan has magic-based
abilities as the name implies like scarlet witch
speed has quicksilver like abilities as his name
implies and speaking of quicksilver everyone
wondering if he's going to cameo on the series
there was an audition scene for older versions
of the twins when they grow up a little bit
where they talk about a quote-unquote uncle that
they're trying not to disturb in the other room
so because elizabeth olsen and kevin feige and
everyone else has said that they're using this
series to tell all the story and deal with all the
things in scarlet witch's past that they haven't
dealt with yet like they kind of brush over
her character in a lot of the avengers movies
it would make sense that they would address
her grief over the loss of her brother during
this series so they would mention him even if he
doesn't appear on screen so there'll probably be
some quicksilver stuff happening during the series
there been a lot of rumors about how they do that
or which characters they introduce or which actors
they bring on the series we'll just find out when
they drop the episodes you also see another scene
with grown-up versions of the twins going outside
with scarlet witch in this scene here it looks
like they're in the 80s or 90s based on the
model of cara in their driveway and they're just
walking outside behind her then when they jump to
what seems like present day like they're going
through the decades they finally get to present
day they're looking out the window all worried
about fighting for their alternate reality because
it seems like sword randall park's character
darcy all the other people that are working with
nick fury are freaking out about what scarlet
witch is doing like who's doing this to you
the funny thing about that twist is that they
actually think that she's being hurt or forced
to do this by someone else they don't know yet
at this point that she's doing it to herself but
if you look in the background of this scene here
you can actually see a family photo with a faint
outline of the twins who at this point are fully
grown the whole point as you probably guessed in
aging them up so quickly using scarlet witch's
powers and the trippy way time moves in her
alternate reality is so that they can eventually
do a young avengers crossover story with the
other new members of the team they're introducing
through the other series the next couple of years
during the disney investor meeting they announced
those 10 new shows that they're going to drop on
disney plus in the next couple of years based on
the characters they're introducing there should
be no doubt that regardless of what they decide
to call it or where they decide to drop it or
whatever form it takes there is a young avengers
type of group that's coming up so it sounds like
marvel's doing the same thing in putting that team
together that they did with the original avengers
during phase one like you do each of them in their
own movies their own projects then eventually once
they're all introduced they all team up right now
if we're just talking about the younger characters
like teenage very young characters the roster
would be wiccan and speed from Wandavision cassie
lang from ant-man 3 which has now been recast as
katherine newton you probably remember her from
something pretty recently miss marvel from her
series those episodes are actually going to drop
later in 2021 then kate bishop hawkeye played by
hailee steinfeld you've all seen the pictures of
her those episodes will also drop later in 2021
we have america chavez from doctor strange 2 and
then riri williams from the ironheart series they
just announced now the list doesn't include other
teenage characters in the mcu right now like
spider-man he's still technically a teenager
but he was given membership as an a-list avenger
during avengers infinity war so i don't really
think of him as a young avenger the rumor right
now is that sony has already renewed the sharing
deal with marvel again and obviously that'll lead
to more cameos for spider-man in other marvel
phase 5 movies way down the road like spider-man
3 might wind up being the last mcu spider-man
solo movie but it's not the end of tom holland in
the mcu as spider-man spider-man will just cross
over into other people's movies as a big character
like in avengers 5 or other potential movies like
the fantastic four movie because the director he's
been working with for the past six seven years jon
watts is directing the new fantastic four movie
there was even a fantastic four easter egg at
the old avengers tower when it comes down there's
this construction sign heralding the coming of the
fantastic four in marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5. we can't wait to show you what comes next
the whole thing with x-men and mutants though
is that marvel is actually introducing new
x-men characters in a number of different ways
in the next several years so there's no one
single explanation for where x-men come from in
the mcu it's a combination of wish it dream it
make it real with your magic which is what scarlet
witch is doing with her children those are x-men
characters it's them playing on the idea that
her children in the comics weren't real they were
fake but in the series they fight for their
reality so she probably finds a way to bring
them outside of this bubble reality into
the main mcu reality then there's the x-men
multiverse explainer pre-existing characters from
the fox movies coming back for cameos like they've
already confirmed that ryan reynolds is going to
come into the mcu as deadpool eventually then you
have the more complicated eternals explainer that
they'll get into during that movie like celestials
messing with humans in planet earth and then
eventually leading to humans evolving the x gene
like x-men have been here this whole time
we just haven't seen them because a lot of
their powers the x-gene have not manifested yet
really good example of that is kevin feige told
a story a long time ago where he said that he
tried to get a hugh jackman wolverine cameo in
captain america the first avenger way back in
marvel phase one because wolverine is a very
old character he fought in world war ii before he
became wolverine when he still had the bone claws
also before this kevin feige also introduced the
weapons plus programs through the incredible hulk
and thunderbolt ross that's actually coming back
around again during falcon and winter soldier with
the super soldier serum i'll talk about that when
we get to the falcon and winter soldier episodes
but weapons plus is the program that weapon x or
weapon 10 comes from weapon x is just the 10th
iteration of the weapons plus program so it's
just a way for them to slowly introduce these
characters and say see they've been here this
whole time you just haven't seen them till now
and like i just talked about that fantastic four
easter egg and spider-man far from home they're
doing the exact same thing with the new mcu
version of fantastic four we're going to start
getting kang the conqueror through the loki series
in ant-man 3. his real name is nathaniel richards
he's the descendant of reed richards so if he
exists that consequently means that reed richards
exists in the mcu so everyone let me know in the
comments if you spotted any of the big x-men or
mutants easter eggs in the Wandavision trailer
so far we'll get a couple more trailers for that
before the series actually gets here my next video
will be for the mandalorian season 2 episode 8
that'll post on friday just like normal it's the
finale so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that there'll be a
lot of big stuff coming up i feel like i'm still
missing a lot of the news that they announced last
week there was so much of it there's just no way
that i could do all the videos in a single week
so everybody get hyped for 2021 it already looks
like it's going to be so much better than 2020.
everyone click here for my loki trailer video
easter eggs and all the other marvel trailers
from this past week and click here for my brand
new mandalorian season 2 video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!